lyne morissette et professeur associé à
l'institut des sciences de la mer de
rimouski bonsoir bonsoir c'est fillon
alors comment on en est venu à
déterminer cette liste de six produits
lalano ce qui a été fait l'année
dernière de prendre ce grand virage là
qui est mondial de bannir les produits
en plastique ça a été fait deux ans
avant la date de mise en opération de ça
et puis le raison de ce délai leur
c'était justement pour identifier les
produits pour lesquels il existait une
alternative et puis les produits qui
serait relativement facile à enrayer de
notre quotidien et parce que parce que
c'est bien beau de vouloir bannir le
plastique et c'est vraiment souhaitable
de faire mais encore faut-il être
capable de le remplacer par quelque
chose donc le critère c'est ça est-ce
qu'on a une solution de remplacement
maintenant qui nous permet d'enlever ce
produit que de plastique à usage unique
rapidement oui puis dans une certaine
facilité pour les gens qui vont devoir
faire ce changement là et puis dans le
cas des six produits qui ont été
annoncés aujourd'hui
moi personnellement je m'attendais à ce
que la liste soit un peu plus long que
ça mais c'est effectivement des produits
comme les pages où les bâtonnets à café
pour lesquels on peut facilement avoir
une alternative puis pour lesquelles ça
modifiera pas beaucoup le quotidien la
plupart des gens qui utilisent ces
objets en plastique et c'est l'étonnante
les bouteilles de plastique ne soit pas
la triste oui étonnant pas tellement on
comprend là l'ampleur de l'industrie qui
est derrière la fabrication de ces
bouteilles d'eau en plastique et ses
bouteilles en plastique en général
donc je trouve que la liste qu'on voit
aujourd'hui est très prudente
ça dérange ni les habitudes des jeunes
et les grandes industries avec leur lot
béquille qui ont probablement beaucoup
de forces à essayer de maintenir
l'industrie
alors ça donne quoi de faire ça si ça
dérange pas grand chose au final
mais en fait c'est sûr que on sauvera
pas la planète en interdisant les
pailles ou les sacs en plastique mais ce
que ça a réussi à faire c'est générer
commencer à générer sur le réflexe là
d'utiliser moins de plastique et puis de
trouver des alternatives qui sont pas en
plastique
donc au delà de l'appareil ce qu'on va
faire en bannissant ces objets là c'est
de créer chez les canadiens des réflexes
de l'utilisation durable de toutes
sortes de produits
parce que parce que évidemment c'est
post cette quantité l'autre plastique
qui va faire une grosse différence au
final mais est ce qu'elles vont faire
quand même une est-ce qu'on va réduire
la pollution et inutilement aussi nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre avec
ça mais évidemment que ça va faire une
différence parce que c'est des objets
qui qui qui polluent qui ont un usage
très très très court en terme de durée
dans le temps
versus l'utilisation qu'on en fait
versus l'impact que cela peut avoir sur
la pérennité nos écosystèmes
donc oui ça va faire une différence mais
ça va aussi générer ce premier polo vert
une beaucoup plus grosse différence
qu'il va falloir faire parce que on
aimait encore beaucoup plus de plastique
qu'on sera jamais capable de limiter en
termes de décisions gouvernementales ou
de nettoyage des rivages par exemple la
source est beaucoup plus grande que ce
qu'ont réussi à limiter parler aux
interventions comme l'interdiction des
sacs de plastique mais on peut pas on
s'entend bannir le plastique jour au
lendemain surtout que du plastique on a
un autre des produits absolument
essentiel du matériel médical par
exemple dans les voitures également
exactement donc si c'est pour ça qu'on a
ciblé des objets qui étaient
relativement facile à remplacer parce
qu'on n'aurait pas plu jour au lendemain
dire aux gens aux entreprises ou aux
consommateurs canadiens bon mais à
partir de demain on met plus de
plastique dans les autos qu'est ce qui
serait arrivé
on n'aurait pas eu de solution pour
continuer à produire ces voitures là par
exemple avec une alternative ou une
solution de remplacement
donc là on a ciblé les produits qui
étaient facilement éliminables puis je
pense que c'est un bon un bon départ
mais il va falloir en faire beaucoup
plus que ça pour avoir un vrai mais cela
dit il ya un impact sur les entreprises
c'est quoi les répercussions économiques
pour les entreprises d'éliminer comme ça
relativement rapidement là compte tenu
des attentes aujourd'hui
de l'utilisation du plastique mais pour
les entreprises qui doivent changer
par exemple les ustensiles pour des
options qui sont pas en plastique ça
comporte des coûts qui sont quand même
assez important par exemple quand on va
chez le dentiste puis qu'on y donne la
fameuse brosse à dents qui est en
plastique je parlais à mon dentiste
dernièrement puis elle me disait
remplacée par une brosse à dents en
bambou ces trois fois le prix donc pour
eux a opté pour des options qui sont en
plein plastique c'est une augmentation
de coût par contre moi j'ai bon espoir
que la demande du consommateur offert en
somme que ces entreprises là vont être
favorisés quand quand on va devoir faire
un choix entre une entreprise qui
utilise du plastique d'une entreprise
qui ont eu un service simple est mal à
marseille je vous aurais dit sisi tout
le temps qu'on a c'était très
intéressant à la prochaine c'est un
plaisir à voir